welcome back everyone as president trump
attended the commemoration of the 100th
anniversary of the end of the first
world war
his host president macron launched an
extraordinary direct
political attack here's what donald
trump said
a few weeks ago you know they have a
word
it sort of became old-fashioned it's
called a nationalist
and i say really we're not supposed to
use that word you know what i am i'm a
nationalist okay
i'm a national
so who on earth could emmanuel macron
have meant when he
said this today patriotism is the exact
opposite of nationalism nationalism
is a betrayal
we erase what a nation holds dearest
what gives it life
what makes it grace and what is
essential
its moral values
all right so let's take his words at
face value he said
patriotism is the exact opposite of
nationalism is it i looked it up
on google the definition of nationalism
is quote patriotic feeling principles or
efforts
the first synonym that means the same
meaning as not the opposite
listed for nationalism is literally
patriotism
and that's according to the globalists
at google but let's go beyond semantics
let's take his
argument such as it is seriously the
president of france is saying it's wrong
to put your own country's interest first
he thinks something else perhaps the
european interest or the global interest
should come first
but who decides what that is where does
its legitimacy come from
how is it accountable and to whom what
is macron's mandate
exactly for privileging the european or
the global
over the national he was elected with
french votes
not global votes just like president
trump was elected with american votes
at least he seems to understand that and
understand who he's accountable to
macron's attack on president trump was
highly revealing
it lays bare the astonishing arrogance
of the globalist ruling class
who think it's their moral duty to
ignore democracy
and instead run the world according to
whatever makes life easier
for the ruthless and heartless global
corporations that macron and his gang
of davos elitists cravenly serve
and they have the nerve to lecture
president trump about morality
one last point on all this i was reading
this book
what is the constitution with one of my
sons this week it tells the story of the
constitution and here's something
that caught my eye
some leaders like george washington
james madison
and alexander hamilton wanted the united
states to be a strong nation
with a solid central government one that
would oversee all the states
these leaders were called nationalists
so alexander hamilton was a nationalist
perhaps that might convince the elites
that there really is nothing wrong with
putting your country
first in fact it's the only truly
democratic thing
to do